this video is kindly sponsored by surf
shark
the fastest and easiest vpn find out
more
later in the video hey 42 here
as anyone who's lived through high
school will tell you
the world can be a ruthless place
we humans seem to spend a lot of our
time competing for things
money power market share
love and detention that last piece of
birthday cake
and with the world population growing
faster than a herd of nymphomaniacal
rabbits
competition for resources is only going
to get
more intense but we are not only
competing against each other
there are thousands upon thousands of
other species out there
going about their daily business too
two varying degrees we are also
competing with all of them
for basics like food water and
land and so far
it looks like we're crushing it
according to research by the worldwide
fund for nature
wildlife populations across the world
have declined by an average of 68
since 1970 mostly due to human
impact so in the race for survival
there's really no contest if this were
a hundred meter sprint we'd be usain
bolt
and the rest of nature would be your nan
on ketamine this level of domination
may fill you with horror or a warm glow
of genocidal pride
but either way you don't need to be a
genius to comprehend that running at
this pace
isn't sustainable since our planet has
finite resources
it's highly likely we won't be able to
consume at our current rate
forever if we're going to survive
people need to find a way to conserve
and replenish
stocks of flora and fauna and
opposite to the thinking that's guided
us most of the last hundred years and
beyond
that does not involve getting rid of the
creatures we consider our main
competition for food
from primary predators to pigs
humans have a long history of hunting
and killing goth species we see as a
threat to our food supply
even today this thinking underpins
government policies for example
after an international ban in place
since 1986
japan recently announced a decision to
resume
commercial whaling part of the
justification for this move was that
whales eat huge amounts of fish as well
as the fish's food
tiny crustacean-like shrimp called krill
the argument goes if we let whales have
their way
there won't be anything left for us at a
glance
this thinking makes sense but's research
over the last few years
suggests that having whales in the ocean
actually increases not decreases
the numbers of fish and krill and the
reason why
may take you completely by surprise if
you enjoy documentaries about wildlife
like me
or anything else for that matter you
should definitely use
surfshark to unlock videos on streaming
services
that might not be available in your
country surfshark runs on any device
anywhere and it's packed full of
features such as industry-leading
uncrackable encryption ip and
dns leak protection an internet kill
switch of your vpn drops out
and 24 7 customer support surfshark
maintains a strict
no logs policy and their network of 3200
servers
in over 65 countries runs 100
on ram so they couldn't log your data
even if they wanted to by using
surfsharkvpn you can stay anonymous and
secure online
personally i use surfshark to watch
netflix content from other countries
such as the us that's usually blocked
here in the uk
by using the code 42 you'll benefit from
an 83
discount plus free extra months for
free all you have to do is click the
special link in the description below
don't miss out in case you hadn't
noticed
whales are big really big
blue whales are the biggest species to
ever exist on the planet
yes even bigger than those dinosaurs
with their ridiculously long necks
and that big silly flying lizard i
talked about recently
they have a heart the size of a small
car
which can be heard beating from two
miles away
and some arteries are so large a small
person can crawl through
as you can imagine a creature this size
needs to eat a lot one blue whale can
eat
40 million krill a day
but as you can also imagine
what goes in must come out
what i'm trying to say is whales
are massive factories you've
probably not spent too much time
wondering about this
that's why i'm here to ask all the
really tough questions
on your behalf but i think it's pretty
easy to accept that whales produce
a lot of pain enormous clouds of the
stuff actually
known as fecal plumes in a hypothetical
process called the whale pump
whales are fought to dive deep below the
waves to search for food
and then when they return to the surface
to breathe
they release poop plumes usually in the
photic zone
the upper level of the sea in which
there's enough light for photosynthesis
to happen
because in sunlight is just
more pleasant
this fabulous feces is rich in iron and
nitrogen which are rare minerals this
high in the ocean strata
and it acts as a fertilizer for
microscopic marine
algae called phytoplankton
formed the foundation for ocean food
webs
acting as the food source for small fish
and crustaceans
who in turn act as the food source
for bigger fish and so on
so more whale poo equals more nutrients
for phytoplankton
equals more food for everyone
studies suggest that ocean areas with
higher whale populations
have higher densities of phytoplankton
fish and sea life all the way up the
food chain
the increased phytoplankton from the
whale pump could also have other
benefits
phytoplankton absorb around 40 percent
of the carbon from the atmosphere
which is equivalent to four amazon
rainforests
and produce about half of the world's
oxygen
making it a major influencer in climate
change
so it could be that rather than
threatening human food supply whales
actually support and increase it
and possibly improve the climate whilst
they're at it too
these huge blubbery beasts are able to
have
such an outsized impact due to an
ecological process
called a trophic cascade which describes
what happens to a food chain
and the ecosystem around it when a top
predator is added or taken away
imagine for example a simple free tier
food chain with a carnivore at the top
known as the predator a herbivore below
called the primary consumer
and plants at the bottom known as the
primary producers
until the middle of the 20th century it
was widely believed that ecosystems were
governed
by primary producers essentially the
size and diversity of a habitat
as well as the sizes of animal
populations at all stages in the food
chain
were determined by how much food there
was
at the very bottom of the pyramid
usually in the form of plants
or phytoplankton predators just
weren't considered to play a
particularly meaningful role
if there were lots of primary producers
there could be more primary consumers to
eat
them and then there would be more
predators to eat
them at least that's what was assumed
the problem with this theory was if the
entire ecosystem was regulated by food
supply
at the bottom of the chain what stops
the animal populations in the middle
from growing unstoppably and decimating
all the green stuff the answer to this
little puzzler
emerged in the 1960s the theory of
trophic
cascades and along with it
the concept of keystone species
in a trophic cascade predators at the
top of the pyramid
are just as important as the producers
at the bottom
if you reduce the number of carnivores
at the top
the population of herbivores is likely
to expand
because there's nothing to keep it in
check and
more herbivores usually equals
overgrazing of plants
which can destroy an ecosystem
because reduced vegetation causes
increased soil erosion
which in turn leads to silted up rivers
and so on on the other hand having more
predators at the top
keeps the populations of herbivores
under control
which allows plants to flourish this is
known
as a top-down trophic cascade
for a real world example in the kelp
forests in the pacific ocean
sea otters feed on sea urchins
who in turn graze on the kelp
in some areas otters have been
extripated
which means their numbers have been
reduced to extinction within that region
usually through excessive hunting where
this has happened
sea urchin populations have increased so
much
that the kelp has been almost totally
deforested
the opposite of this is known as a
bottom
up trophic cascade in which
the primary producer at the bottom of
the chain sets the limit
for the rest of it because phytoplankton
and plants rely on photosynthesis
variations in sunlight can cause
big issues affecting nutrient levels
when there's an abundance of nutrients
generally all
trophic levels prosper together however
a lack of nutrients at the bottom can
decimate
the entire pyramid all the way up to the
carnivores at the top
[Music]
the most famous and arguably most
interesting
example of a trophy cascade is the
reintroduction
of grey wolves into the yellowstone
national park in the united states
when yellowstone was established in 1872
there was no legal protection on the
wildlife in the park
so tourists and hunters had the right to
kill
anything they wanted protective laws
were put in place a few years later
but predators were excluded
so by 1926
wolves had been hunted to extinction
in yellowstone but when the wolves
disappeared
populations of their number one prey the
elk
increased massively and hence
the ecological conditions within the
park
drastically declined biologists were
worried about
erosion and the overgrazing of woody
plants like willow
aspen and cottonwood so population
control programs were started
which basically involves moving elk
around or killing them
because you know what us humans are like
if we don't know how to fix something
we just kill it these programs helped
slow the negative impact on the
territory
but the vegetation and landscape didn't
recover
so in the 1940s campaigns began
for gray wolves to be reintroduced into
the park
the general public tend to feel about
wolves the same way they feel about
say sharks or gonorrhea
so there wasn't an overwhelming amount
of support for having wolves back at
yellowstone
things began to change in the 1960s
though
the free love movements meant there was
a lot more gonorrhea
and better understanding of ecosystems
meant there was more support for having
wolves back in yellowstone
in 1969 zoologist robert payne
introduced the concept of the keystone
species
which describes an animal that's able to
influence an
entire habitat on its own
all animals in a particular area may
have their place in the trophic pyramid
but not all of them can fundamentally
shift the way that pyramid works
keystone species have that ability
they are essentially ecosystem engineers
and the wolf is one of them
a few short decades later in january
14 wolves imported from canada
were released into yellowstone national
park
it was a rare situation in which the
trophic cascade
from the reintroduction of an apex
predator
could be monitored and compared to the
environment
that existed before as a result
scientists have spent the last 25 odd
years
studying the impact of the wolves at
yellowstone
and arguing about what all of it means
one version of events popularized by a
video that went viral
no not gonorrhea was that the
reintroduction of the wolves
not only had an impact on the population
of elk in the park
but also elk behavior for the first time
in
70 years elk needed to be more wary
of attack and began to avoid areas where
they felt vulnerable
such as valleys and gorges so
vegetation in those areas began to
regenerate
with some trees showing a five-fold
increase in
height in just six years deforested
areas saw new growth of trees like
willow aspen and cottonwood which
in turn saw greater biodiversity with
the return of the birds and insects who
lived in those trees
the resurgence of willow trees was a
particularly big
deal because these are favorites of
beavers who eat willow
and use it to build their dams and
lodges like
wolves beavers are a keystone species
so they began to have a dramatic impact
on the environment
between 1996 and 2009
the number of beaver colonies in
yellowstone increased
from 1 to 12.
and importantly they weren't restricted
to the main rivers
but began frequenting the smaller
outlying rivers
too the dams the beavers built created
new habitats of their
own with fish aquatic birds muskrats
and other water mammals also the wolves
killed coyotes
which allowed populations of coyote prey
to flourish
which is mostly small mammals like mice
and rabbits
which in turn attracted species that
hunt mice and rabbits
like weasels foxes and birds of prey
the carcasses that the wolves left
behind after their feeding
attracted scavengers like bald eagles
and ravens
bears also profited from having more
carrion lying around
and because there were now more shrubs
there were also more
berries but perhaps most amazingly of
all
the wolves even changed the behavior
of the rivers due to more widespread
vegetation growth and regenerating
forests
river banks were stabilized and soil
erosion decreased
leading to deeper less meandering rivers
with more pools and less silt all of
which
was good for local habitats the primary
message was
even though there were only a few wolves
to start with in 1995
the fact they were a keystone species in
a trophic cascade
meant they had the power to change
not only the ecosystem of yellowstone
national park
but also the physical landscape of the
environment
itself that's a pretty amazing story
but is it true scientists generally
agree that trophic cascades
are a genuine and credible phenomenon
but zoologists biologists ecologists
and gynecologists continue to argue
about the wolves and beavers in
yellowstone
no one is debating whether wolves had an
impact on elk populations since they
returned to the park
but what is questioned is whether they
can be declared
responsible for the shifts in vegetation
and
therefore the rivers the ecosystem at
yellowstone national park
is very complex and it's impossible to
say for certain that one change at the
top of the food chain
is responsible for a linear change all
the way at the bottom
for example in the same period of time
since wolves came back to the park
grizzly bear and cougar populations have
increased
and bears specifically are a natural
predator of elk calves
hunting by humans is also responsible
for smaller elk populations
with thousands of animals killed when
herds cross the border
and leave the park for some parts of the
year
other elk have contracted diseases from
the growing number of bison
yellowstone has also experienced
significant drought in recent years
which has impacted animal populations
but also revealed some facts about
willow growth
willows need water to flourish and the
discrepancies in tree growth
brought on by drought has highlighted
that the rise and fall of willow density
across the park
can't be attributed to one single cause
the science around trophic cascades is
still emerging
and it seems clear that stories about
river-moving wolves and
poop-plooming whales
highly complex systems and ecological
processes
but they do shine light on how
interconnected the different elements of
the natural world
are and if that's going to encourage
humans to make better decisions about
how
and where we fit in i'm all for it
thank you for watching